back in this country the newest GOP
Challengers to former president Donald
Trump are his former vice president and
the man who led his presidential
transition team Mike Pence launched his
campaign for the Republican nomination
in an online video overnight and Chris
Christie kicked off his campaign in New
Hampshire Bob Costa is in Des Moines
Iowa where Pence will appear later today
it's also his birthday I hear Bob good
morning
Good morning Tony following up on that
video announcement former vice president
Mike Pence will make his announcement at
an event here in Iowa later today
casting himself as an alternative to
former president Donald Trump and last
night in New Hampshire Christie also
cast himself as an alternative to Trump
and as someone more than happy to take
on the former president directly
I intend to seek the Republican
nomination for president United States
in 2024 and I want your support
announcing his bid for the White House
Tuesday former New Jersey Governor Chris
Christie wants a trump Ally is now
calling out the former president by name
the reason I'm going after Trump is
twofold
one he deserves it
and two it's the way to win Trump
responded in a pose Colleen Christie a
failed Governor writing this time it
won't be any different God is not done
with America yet and together we can
bring this country back today former
vice president Mike Pence released a new
political ad and will also officially
jump into the race choosing to do it in
Iowa the home to the caucuses and where
he has been busy courting fellow
religious conservatives we need to stand
firm on the conservative agenda of life
and Liberty and a commitment to Freedom
Penn served as Trump's running mate
twice friends and neighbors asked me
back in Indiana said what is it about
Donald Trump and I say Donald Trump just
you know Donald Trump gets it but ever
since Pence was pressured by Trump to
try to overturn the 2020 election I hope
Mike is going to do the right thing I
hope so and face threats during the
January 6 attack on the capitol
[Applause]
there one strong Alliance has
increasingly become a rivalry and Pence
has since testified before a Federal
grand jury investigating the conduct of
trump and his allies the president's
words and actions
in and around January 6 were Reckless
endangered my family and endangered
people that were in the capital and was
indefensible
North Dakota governor Doug burgum will
also get into the presidential race
today with an event in Fargo North
Dakota Pence's candidacy though this is
something you so rarely see in American
history a former vice president running
against his former boss just weeks after
he testified in an ongoing federal
investigation about an attack on the
capital of the United States what a time
in American politics